dolly first off you are such
unbelievable
positivity and especially through all of
this this year
how do you do it i guess is the main
question how do you remain
the most positive human anybody has ever
met
how do i not do it people need some
light and some sunshine and people need
to know that
people are out there still doing things
and i always say that every day when i
wake up i ask god to use me
to let me shine and radiate with his
love and light and let me uplift people
and glorify him so i set out about my
day
trying to do that and i'm not wanting to
lay around and mope around
and be i mean even when you don't like
what you're seeing like with all this
coving stuff
i think well i've still got to be
productive i still need to do something
so i just want to make people feel good
and which makes me feel good and
so it's working so far i love it
christine when you're doing this type of
christmas story somebody's got to learn
a lesson and somebody has to be awful
um how fantastic was it how fantastic
was it at least for the most part to get
to play somebody
so awful this is not my first grinch
oh no it's not you show up and you show
up in a nice coat and a christmas movie
nothing good is gonna happen
oh nothing good but i'll be well dressed
and have a lot of one-liners
but yeah she's particularly i think this
woman really has a hard edge because
she's trying to sell off the whole town
and she tells them all that they have to
be out by christmas eve i mean how mean
is that
and uh one of my first scenes in the
movie i'm just mean to
dolly parton dressed as an angel so you
got to be really hard
very hard to do that so you know she is
redeemed at the end
and it's a wonderful journey because you
know we like to see
people we like to see that
transformation we like to believe that
people with hard hearts
can soften and learn lessons we're all
trying to learn those lessons and
we all got a lot of stuff old crusty
stuff inside that needs to be softened
and so yeah i i thought it was wonderful
to play this bro
uh dolly have you ever felt like you had
a guardian angel have you ever felt like
you needed one
i feel like i always have one i i'm very
much a
spirit person i just kind of live in the
spirit yeah i just feel like there's
things out there
and i always feel protected and so
uh it was easy and fun for me to play an
angel like i'm certainly no angel but it
was fun to play one on tv as they say
but yeah i do feel like i'm surrounded
with light and love and
angels guardian angels so yeah i'm i'm
just one of those kind of people
sappy like that when the when the rest
of us
are all listening to dolly on christmas
morning
what are you listening to well
i'm listening to uh probably something
frying on the stove
something i'm getting ready
i'm probably just listening to all that
kind of stuff getting prepared for
christmas knocking around in the kitchen
doing whatever we do to get ready for
for the day
but i love it i don't really i i turn on
all the christmas music i have every
album
of every christmas thing i i still love
playing mine in kenny rogers christmas
album you do
uh i have that in my house and uh i play
that
and i don't usually listen to myself but
i enjoy that one because
it's got candy on it but i enjoy just
listening to christmas
music i i just turn on the music and
cook and get ready for
family to come over and just have a big
time and uh quickly before i go
christine um i'm getting the sense from
everybody else that as soon as somebody
says the name dolly parton and project
you say yes immediately
is that accurate yeah absolutely
it's such a privilege for me to have you
know i've had a long career and i've
worked with wonderful people
but um dolly parton that's like the
cherry on top but the sunday isn't it
amazing thank you
[Music]
yeah you guys are both wonderful
it was so lovely to to hang out
hopefully next time we do this we'll all
be in the same room but uh
congratulations
on everything and uh happy holidays
thank you merry christmas
you